in the last video
i dropped myself or a penny from the top
of a cliff and uh you know started off
at zero
velocity obviously because it was
stationary and at the bottom was 100
meters per second
and we use that to figure out how high
the cliff was
right and we got we figured out that the
cliff was 500 meters high so what i want
to do now is is let's do that same
problem but let's do it in a general
form and see if we can figure out kind
of a general formula for for a problem
like that
so let's say that
you have
the same thing let's say
the initial velocity
well actually we're going to keep
everything let's say you're given the
initial velocity
you're given the final velocity
you're given the acceleration
and you want to figure out the distance
so this is what you're given
so
doing it the exact same way we did in
that last in in that last uh
presentation but now we're just gonna
stay in formulas we know that
the change in distance
the change in distance is equal to
the average velocity
times
unless we could actually say the change
in time but i'll just say it with time
because we always assume that we start
time equals zero times time
well we know that the average velocity
the average velocity is what it's the
final velocity
plus
the initial velocity
divided by two
so that's the average velocity so let me
let me highlight in the right this is
the same thing as this
and then that times time
well what's the time
well the time you can figure out the
time by saying well we know how fast
we're accelerating and we know the
initial and final velocity so we can
figure out how much how long
we had to accelerate that fast to get
that change in velocity or another way
of saying that probably a simpler way of
saying that is
change in velocity
which is the same thing as the final
velocity minus the initial velocity
is equal to
acceleration times time
right
or if you want to solve for time you
could say the time
right if i just divide both sides of
this equation by a is equal to
vf
minus
vi
divided by a
right
so then we can take that and substitute
that into this equation and remember
this is all change in distance so you
say change in distance
is equal to so the first this term let
me write this term in
in yellow
v f plus v i
over two
and let me write this term in i don't
know green
so that's times
vf
minus vi
over a i like this green i don't know
why i don't ever use it
and then if we multi you know do a
little you know
multiplying of expressions on the top
you might recognize this this would be
vf squared
minus vi squared
and then you multiply the denominators
over 2a so the change in distance is
equal to vf squared minus vi squared
over 2a
that's exciting let me write that over
again
image invert colors so the change in
distance
the change in distance is equal to
the vf squared
minus vi
squared
divided by the
two times acceleration
and we could play around with this a
little bit and if we assume that we
started distance is equal to zero we
could just write d here and that might
simplify things if we multiply both
sides by 2a we get
2a and i'm just going to switch this to
distance if we if we assume that we
always started distance is equal to zero
d
d i or initial distance is always at
point zero
but we could write two a d right i'm
just multiplying both sides by two a
is equal to v
f squared
minus
vi squared
or you could write it as
vf squared
is equal to vi squared
plus
a d
and you'll i don't know what your
physics teacher might show you or what's
written in your physics book but one
very one of these variations will show
up in your physics book but the reason
why i wanted to show you that previous
problem first is i i wanted to show you
that you could actually figure out these
problems without having to always you
know memorize formulas and resort to the
formula but with that said it's probably
not a bad idea to memorize some form of
this formula although you should
understand how it was derived and and
when to apply it
so let's let's with that you know now
that you have memorized it or i've shown
you that maybe you don't have to
memorize it let's let's use this
so let's say i have the same clip and it
has now turned purple
and it's what did i say it was it was
500 meters high right it's a 500 meter
high cliff
and this time with the penny instead of
just dropping it straight down i'm gonna
throw it straight up
at i don't know let's say positive 30
meters per second and and the positive
matters because remember we said
negative is down positive is up that's
just the convention we use so let's use
let's use
this formula which you know any any
version of this formula to figure out
let's use it to figure out what our
final velocity was when we when we hit
when we hit the bottom of the ground
well this is this is probably the
easiest formula to use because it
actually solves for final velocity
so we can say that the final velocity
vf
squared is equal to the initial velocity
squared so it's our initial velocity
it's plus 30 meters per second right so
it's 30
meters per second
squared
plus 2ad so 2 a is the acceleration of
gravity which is minus 10 because it's
going down right
so it's 2
i don't want to run out of space times
minus 10. i'm going to give up the units
for a second just so i don't run out of
space 2 times -10 and then what's the
height
what's the change in distance
actually i should be i should be correct
about using change in distance because
it matters for this problem
right so in this case this is this is
the final volt distance is equal to -500
right
and the initial distance is equal to
zero so the change in distance is minus
right
so what does this get us so we get
vf
squared is equal to 900
and then the negatives cancel out ten
times five hundred is five thousand
five thousand times two
five thousand times two is ten thousand
so v f
squared vf squared
is equal to
ten thousand
nine hundred
so the final velocity is equal to
the square root
of ten thousand
and 900. so what is that well let me let
me let me
let me
bring over my trusty
windows provided default calculator
let's see what is it 10
nine
hundred
square root
so it's about a hundred
four
meters per second 104 meters per second
so my let me get this out of the way
so my final velocity
is approximately that squiggly equals is
approximately 104
meters per second
that's interesting if i just drop
something
if i just drop it straight from the top
we figure out the last problem at the
end i'm at 100 meters per second right
but this time if i throw it straight up
at 30 meters per second when i hit the
when the penny hits the ground it's
actually going even faster and so you
might want to think about why that is
and and you might realize it because
when i throw it up the highest point of
the penny if i throw it up at 30 meters
per second the highest point of the
penny is going to be higher than 500
meters right it's going to make some
positive distance first and then it's
going to come down so it's going to have
even more time to accelerate and you can
i mean
i think that makes some intuitive
sense to you
so that's all the time i have now and in
the next presentation maybe i'll use
this formula to solve a couple of other
types of problems